you know I think about your career so
you were on a musical path and by the
way you've had like five hit albums and
everything I mean you know you're kind
of lucky though I mean I love that Kanye
West Kanye is brilliant because he goes
beyond wrapping his soul he gives
everybody an opportunity to hate him
yeah in a sense he'll give everybody a
situation where you question but his
talent is amazing I'm gonna tell you how
I met Kanye I would throw parties for
music people so I could get into music
business I couldn't get into music biz
everybody laughs I was wanted from a
little color I can't take you seriously
Dan you look like mother to me so I
throw parties for music guys and I had a
studio on my cream I say hey listen soon
it won't you leave me eight bars right
you know like a sing too so I throw this
big party for puff and at the time puff
was huge it was the biggest hear Bad Boy
Records on and did he I would follow him
I couldn't get into his parties so I
would show up with a camera like the
like a paparazzi
that's a puffy oh you need somebody to
document this [ __ ] and it wasn't like
the little iPhone it was a big intrusive
Canon and let me change my battery and
all that [ __ ] in the light so one day
exactly one day where Philly and he
throws his incredible parties he's your
Playboy you see this part I said [ __ ] is
amazing he says I spent a million and a
half dollars on his party I said that's
[ __ ] crazy
he's on money I don't know whose money
was I said a million dollars a party
he said yeah I said well I'll throw your
party at my crib in LA that can't rival
this on scale but it'll be a party
you'll never forget and I kind of I kind
of pissed him off he got mad because he
was you're competing with his party no
I'm not competing with Jesse I'm just
telling you in LA I throw the nicest
little boutique parties so he gets to LA
he calls me on the side and said yo I'm
here to make that [ __ ] happen I said I'm
on it so I'm going to my phone right and
I call about maybe I had a little small
house so maybe like 200 or dopest people
when you say dopest people are you
talking like a major recording artist
just the motor the most beautiful people
high-tech but at the same time the most
in touch like movers and shakers no what
I mean is like like the grip on it they
know what's happening they know how to
party
cool crowd right so I didn't invite no
knuckleheads it was mad at puffs cause
it was you know saying cuz la you give
me a [ __ ] can't what 900 at my homies we
were there to celebrate him and the girl
so I hit him at 12 I said yo where you
at it's fevered pitch right he shows up
and he walks and says oh that's the girl
from so and that's the girl on this
stuff I said yeah well I told you we're
gonna blow fire yeah and then I said I
told him I said my party $400 fried
chicken but I put it in a nice plate
yeah so we having a great time right
he's having a ball
I'm Missy shook Missy L it shows up so
these guys hang out with you and they
see Missy Elliott and all of a sudden
they look at you as a musician in assist
puff has room Missy lehand i'ma tell you
how long ago was that was guy standing
on the wall with a green jump suit
jacket on nobody knew who he was and
they was jay-z that was jay-z huh I'm
walking to my garage it's two guys one
little guy want our God the little guy
goes you'll be it's like this all the
time be in girls and stuff like that say
yeah you who you over the Neptune's I
said really
yeah I said my name is Furillo I said
yeah yeah yeah so I had all these people
at math so so you got a very cool scene
happened it was really cool man so I'm
having another party and all of a sudden
this kid walks in with a backpack oh
yeah he's y'all kind of messed up job
mesda yes Joe was kind of fat yeah I
said who said dude I said oh that's a
new dude Kanye
oh I said what does he do see yo he bout
to be the next guy I said please come on
let me hear and so I will always make
people perform in my house
he freestyle money I said damn man you
the baddest [ __ ] no you rent you
can recognize real talent to me I just
thought I'd never heard anything like
that
it was like a person from outer space
the way he was freestyle and he doesn't
mind freestyling for it at that time it
was amazing he was just and then he says
listen I got a song for you I said what
I said
so we go in the back of my studio I said
what's the song he said yo
the song is called slow jabs so he plays
the song and he said this how it goes
she says she loves some Marvin Gaye some
Luther Virgil I said I got it I got it I
started singing she says she won't sue
more bigoted he said what you doing [ __ ]
is that
I said well man I got to put the R&B
[ __ ] on it see you young you know what
the R&B [ __ ] is man I'm trying to he
said don't do that really he doesn't
really yeah he said yeah you little your
little old and the way you're
approaching it right now it's simplicity
now you don't have to do that
just sing it the way I tell you all
right once I sing the way you tell me
I'm thinking he don't know what he told
me he ain't gonna make it this song is
gonna fly so I leave and go do a bad
movie I come back and my boys like
remember that song you fronted on with
Kanye yeah it's number one in the
country Wow and that's how it started
and then Kanye needed a favor in assists
we performed at the Clive Davis party I
bet Clive Davis let me perform because I
didn't have a record deal right and
Clive Davis right well first of all let
me tell you that you know the audience
therapy the musical acraman is amazing
and you know I don't just because you're
a actor doesn't mean that I said man
just please let me perform just let me
perform so I went on stage and I told I
told Kanye Kanye this is a big look for
us me and twisted I said I'm gonna go
out and get the crowd ready because I've
seen people die in this room right I
said but I've told jokes to everybody in
this room right so I go out and I say
man it's a hard ticket to get in here
and everybody's clapping I said yeah you
can't get it I was talking to a lady
outside and she says oh I want to go
into that Clive Davis party I said well
why do you want to go in there because
they got the music I like I said what
kind of music do you like and I'm on the
piano I said you know she told me she
said she want some Marvin Gaye so I sort
of do this little prelude to our song
yeah and then Kanye comes out twister
comes out we get a standing ovation and
I got the record deal that night no [ __ ]
boy you ever really paid off
yeah